he is one of the best in the business
and uh i meant what i said when i
tweeted out this weekend watching him
play uh against the arizona cardinals
that um the the league's better when
he's up and he's active and he's balling
out the man who helped create
uh national tight ends day the tight end
of the san francisco 49ers joining us
prior to the monday night our huge one
for both teams against the rams the
great george kittle how are you george
rich
wow thanks for the intro i'm excited to
be here
uh you know makes my wednesday morning a
little bit better now and i get to talk
to you today i appreciate that wednesday
yeah it's normally known that middle
that middle of the week you don't really
want to deal with it and uh you and i
are just helping each other get through
it so i appreciate that thank you for
that
appreciate it
how are you doing how's it going how's
it going
look we threw it uh i mean
that's he buys some good i'm excited
back playing football for the last
couple weeks being uh being out has been
tough
but uh you know i just felt good to be
back out there in front of our great
fans and playing with the boys again and
you know we didn't get the dub and it
wasn't the game that we wanted to play
um you know so disappointed in that but
uh you know i'm optimistic too we had to
play on monday night football and i
missed that one last year so i'm very
excited that i get an opportunity to
play again uh
the only game of the day on monday night
football so uh very optimistic okay and
so um
what do you lend uh to the three and
five star the reason for it is there one
is there something that you guys are
talking about uh on this front
that you want to just throw out there
right now oh george i mean to me i think
uh we just need to play better yeah
that's all it is at the end of the day
when you look at the tape of every
single game that we've lost and even the
games that we've won i just don't feel
like we've we've played at the level
that you know the standard that we've
set you know i know we have a couple
guys that are playing it consistent at a
higher level i mean i need to elevate my
game um i think you know i think
everybody can just play a little bit
better um you just look at it whether
it's drops
i mean uh i had a bad fumble and you got
a bad fumble you know they didn't set
our defense up for failure so just hey
you got to eliminate those mistakes and
give ourselves a chance because we're
not even doing that i mean coach
shanahan's calling plays to give us
opportunities and we're just not really
taking advantage of those things and so
i really just think it's at the end of
the day we just need to play but i'm uh
you know you could say focus on the
little things and uh you know go back to
work but you know we have been working i
think we've had a lot of really good
practices and we've got to get to
correlate to the game and uh you know
i'm excited about that like i said you
know monday night football we have the
whole nation looking at you it's a
wonderful time to you know get the ball
get the boat going in the right
direction yeah that's right i mean and
it's you and deebo and ayuk i mean
that's
you're back i mean you're all there
right and so uh and jimmy g knows you
you know him
the the pieces are there i just you know
just give
can you give just the fans a little bit
of an insight when you're just like it
just
when it just doesn't all click and and
how you keep fighting through it like
how do you do that you know what i mean
oh it's i mean it's frustrating you know
you you have all the pieces i know i
think that we have a lot of really good
skill position i think we have a
fantastical line
um
and i think jimmy g has given us the
opportunities to make plays he's putting
the ball in the right spots in the last
two weeks he's played really well safe
for a couple passes you know and uh
i just think that uh you know it is it's
fresher when your skill guys you know
when you're not making all the plays
when you're not having um you know all
those pitch and catches like you should
um
it's frustrating but like i said and i
think we're working really hard i think
we're having really good practices and
it just has to correlate and you know
the way you just get through that is you
know it is a couple things you know i
think one of it i think we have a very
mentally tough team i do i think we have
some vets in here that have been through
a lot of stuff that are leading the way
for the young guys and
um you know it is difficult but um at
the end of the day you know i'm a
professional football player living my
dream out every single day so it's hard
not to be positive and so you just got
to bring that energy around and
continue to work hard and get better
every single day and i think that's what
we're doing and i think that we will
continue to get better and like i said
um
the great thing about the nfl is you get
another you get another opportunity in
the next week and so if you keep talking
about the last one it's just going to
hinder you from succeeding at the next
one and i'm very excited about this
monday night football game against the
rams because you know division rival
they're really good they're rolling um
hey but we've had their number last
couple years and um i'm excited to see
what we put together uh tomorrow when we
go in for all of our meetings and stuff
and it's just gonna be another fun game
for us go out there and play is coach
more ornery is he more pissed that's
coach how's your hand up let's let's see
what's up that's great coach
he's great um he's very consistent he's
the same guy every single day you know
he uh
i think it's good that we had an extra
24 hours to watch film
uh you know let him watch it a couple of
times but
he's all right he's uh you know he's
obviously in the same boat as we are
he's disappointed that we're not winning
games
um but you know i think you know we're
underperforming a little bit but i think
that we need you know obviously we need
to win more games and he knows that and
i think that um the good thing about
coach shannon is i think he's built a
really good staff and they're gonna do
everything they can to
make it easier on the guys for them to
understand it or you know just dial up
some more things that give us an
opportunity to win a game all right so
george kittle uh i i you know usually
doesn't happen this way but uh if aaron
donald's on the edge you chip him is
that what you do what do you do george
oh do you give him a chance to make him
laugh
and not anger him okay because he's he's
really good at football and
um he's large
so i'm just gonna do everything i can
you know put a smile on his face okay
and i'll let him know hey aaron i might
be chipping into this play don't throw
me to the ground okay yeah um yeah that
works but right just relax a little bit
so you got to bring your a material
right and we're not talking football you
could bring your a comedy game
to the game
right i appreciate that you know you got
to you got to play an incredibly high
level in the football field every sunday
but right you know if you can bring a
little bit more into it you know like
you can bring a little bit of that into
it you can distract some guys you never
know but uh you know aaron i love
competing against aaron because he's
he's one of one and when you're at share
football field with him um it's
incredible to watch him work um and to
compete against him so i'm very excited
about that you know von miller's gonna
be awesome
right um that's gonna be so much fun
love meeting it's jan ramsey i like i
said i love going to instagrams and i'm
excited to play against cooper cup uh
definitely one of my boys and uh the
season he's been having so that that'll
be uh i mean it's just absolutely
incredible he just cooks dudes left and
right like it's owns business um and so
i'll be excited to watch that in person
as well cup's one of your boys cup's one
of your boys too huh you have a lot of i
mean you you you you have a lot uh you
have a lot of friends in this game
george that's for sure you know what i
i'm lucky to be in a profession where uh
i love almost all of my uh all the
people i work with i'm a big fan of you
know i grew up a football fan so i
appreciate when guys are playing at a
high level or people are you know just
playing good i like watching tape and so
whenever you notice those guys that are
playing at a high level uh you know they
deserve to be rewarded for and they
deserve to be talked about i crushed me
george that you weren't out there for
national titles day this time
i mean it's your day man but and by the
way ever i think every tight end scored
that weekend did you notice that that
literally it was the greatest weekend
for tight ends this year so far and may
have been i mean that actually happened
there was an actual
physical and and tangible on the
scoreboard celebration of national tight
ends day this past it was you know you
just got to speak into existence rich
you know you said it's national tight
end day it was national tight end day
and the boys went off and you just you'd
love to see it so i'm sorry
it's there's no plural it's national
tight end day that's what it is
whatever you wanted to be rich
okay okay
all right so because i called it tight
ends i want to make sure that we're good
you know i want to make sure that it's
all good yeah it is what it is you know
plural non-plural you can be specific
very vague we're tight ends man we all
kind of look the same we all kind of do
the same stuff
coaches get us confused with other
players
this calls by our number it is what it
is don't worry about it
and olson's killing it in the booth i
don't know if you've caught any of his
games that he's calling on fox oh no i
listen the clown yeah cause i was out uh
three weeks with a bye week two so i
gotta listen to him a couple of times
and um he's fun to listen to
uh i think he gives a lot of really good
insight
uh so you just give him an opportunity
to talk about the tight end and i think
he can ramble for about 20 minutes which
i really appreciate he's been killing it
uh um i i would be remiss if i did not
ask you about the previous monday night
football game in which uh cassius marsh
of the chicago bears got a 15-yard flag
because he did
start sauntering towards the pittsburgh
bench and stared at them what'd you
think of that george
oh rich
well
you know i think football is a very
emotional sport
i think um
i think you try i think you try all day
all year round you train as much as you
possibly can
um and so you're gonna be very emotional
and uh
whether it's um
whether you're celebrating whether
you're staring at a guy whether you're
flexing at a guy
i think it's hard to you know not let
all that emotion take over when you make
a big time play
i mean i i know i mean at this point i
wouldn't be surprised if i got flagged
for my first down celebration uh because
usually when i get a first down you know
a big play you like to get up spin the
ball
throw a first down celebration up
i mean it is what it is and um you know
it's tough the guys get flagged for that
no i i feel like i i kind of understand
what the league's doing
um
but at the end of the day it's a very
emotional sport the amount of time like
i said that you put into this game the
grind uh
early mornings late nights studying the
things your body goes through the things
people say to you on social media you
know every once in a while you want to
let that energy out you know
be excited be happy about what you're
doing out there and to get flagged for
it at a pivotal time i think it's is
brutal and it's kind of soul-crushing
yeah especially marsha's story i don't
know if you're fully uh up to speed on
that i wasn't at the time that he was a
steeler cut by the steelers and then he
was on the bears practice squad elevated
for that game
and then made that play
i think it was a kind of how do you like
me now stare in the direction of the
bench not
not not like hey i'm better than you you
know what i'm saying it's just
the whole thing was just i i
i i i i despised it i hated it you know
but i also don't want a player standing
over another guy and barking at him
either but that wasn't that you know
what i'm saying
george um
yeah no i mean
i i agree like
the you know you're standing over guy
you're yawning in the face yeah i mean i
don't i don't know if there's really you
don't need to do that again like you
know i it's football like i've i've had
some stuff happen to me out there that
i'm like ah you know it is what it is
you know he's being like it is what it
is it's annoying but whatever so i know
i can kind of see that but i mean unless
it's doing something derogatory or doing
something
you know
um disrespectful i mean that's kind of
my thing as long as you're not
disrespecting the other person i don't
really think there's that big of an
issue and i think standing there staring
at a guy is not disrespectful
no putting your face mask in his face
mask and tell nothing sucks yeah that's
probably pretty disrespectful
right but uh yeah i mean i i
i it's uh i just i hope that there's
more consistency going forward
george kennel you're the man uh what do
you do in your spare time what do you
love what do you and your wife uh binge
watch what are you watching on tv these
days anything that i should know about
oh my gosh i am so glad that you asked
okay
wow all right we actually so we just got
caught up we're finally caught up
there's two shows that me and claire
watch it's we're on yellowstone okay
incredible okay so much fun
um and then we're also watching seal
team i don't know if you watch that but
it's about navy seals yeah i'm a big fan
of it because uh one of the main actors
is the niners fan max the row so uh he
uh he threw my bobble head in on uh in
his like his cage that he keeps all like
all his weapons in the show
and
and this last episode they made a fred
warner reference after he tackled the
guy
awesome super cool you know borianas is
an eagles fan george so oh i know he is
trusting i uh he wears his philly stuff
all the time i'm like hey max throw a
niners hat on or something
but you like yellowstone right costner's
great in that dude he is awesome rip rip
is my guy
okay
okay
have you checked out ted lasso do you
ever see that one
um ted lasso bridge i feel like if you
know me you know that i've watched it of
course that's what i figured i figured i
like you watch every show and you have a
smile on your face like you said like
why am i smiling so hard
you remind me of the players like
football is life with a big smile on and
just go out and do your thing man you're
that guy for the nfl george football is
life and you smile and you go do your
business that's you hey that's you i
appreciate it you're right that is a
compliment i thank you very much for
that you got it you got it take care of
yourself george kittle appreciate the
time you be well and i look forward to
seeing you on monday night football
oh i can't wait for and i'll see you at
uh titan university next year yeah well
as you know i will be in charge of the
curriculum however you see fit since you
just told me
national tight end day is whatever i
want to make of it so
you know national tight day national
titan day national pike today
[Laughter]
george kittle everybody right here on
the rich eisen show prior to monday
night football
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here